[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the way therefore in which enlightenment
apprehends its object in the first
instance and generally is that it takes
it as pure insight and not recognizing
itself therein declares it to the error
an insight is such consciousness
apprehends an object in such a way that
it becomes the essence of consciousness
or becomes an object which consciousness
permeates in which consciousness
preserves itself abides with itself and
remains present to itself and since it
is thus the movement of the object
brings it into existence it is just this
that enlightenment rightly declares
faith to be when it says that what is
for faith the absolute being is a being
of its own consciousness is its own
thought something that is a creation of
consciousness itself thus what
enlightenment declares to be an error
and a fiction is the very same thing as
enlightenment itself is enlightenment
that wants to teach faith the new wisdom
does not tell it anything new for its
object is also for it just this that is
a pure essence of its own consciousness
so that this consciousness does not take
itself to be lost and negated in that
object but rather puts its trust in it
that is finds itself as this particular
consciousness whereas self-consciousness
precisely in the object whomsoever I
trust his certainty of himself is for me
the certainty of myself I recognize in
him my own being for self know that he
acknowledges it and that it is for him
purpose in essence trust however is
faith because the consciousness of the
believer is directly related to its
object and is thus also intuitively
aware that it is one with it and in it
further since what is object for me is
that in which I recognize myself I am
for myself at the same time in that
object in the form of another self
consciousness that is one which has
become in that object alienated from its
particular individuality
that is from as natural and contingent
existence but which partly remains there
in self-consciousness partly in that
object is an essential consciousness
just as pure insight is the notion of
pure insight implies not merely that
consciousness recognizes itself in the
object of its insight and is immediately
present in it without first leaving the
element of thought and returning into
itself it also implies that
consciousness is aware of itself as
being also the mediating movement aware
of itself as being the activity of
producing the object this unity of
itself as unity of self an object as
thereby explicit for it in thought faith
too is just this consciousness obedience
an action form a necessary moment
through which the certainty that
absolute being is comes about this
action of faith does not indeed make it
appear as if absolute being itself is
produced by it but the absolute being of
faith is essentially not the abstract
essence that would exist beyond the
consciousness of the believer on the
contrary it is the spirit of the
religious community the unity of the
abstract essence and self-consciousness
that it be the spirit of the community
this requires as a necessary moment the
action of the community it is this
spirit only by being produced by
consciousness or rather it does not
exist as the spirit of the community
without having been produced by
consciousness for essential as is the
producing of it this is equally
essentially not the sole ground of
absolute being but only a moment
absolute being is at the same time in
and for itself
paragraph 549 is a very long one and
there's there's a lot going on here I'm
going to go out on a bit of a limb and
say that the Nexus or the kernel that
could be said to consist in in one short
statement of course that's going to
require a lot of unpacking and that's
what I have here in the middle
translated as Trust however is faith
Fattah one is a vertical Alban actually
sounds a little bit better than German
a little bit poetic in some ways right
Trust is is faith now why is that
important because you could say that one
of the things that's been going on all
this time then we saw faith starting to
kick back against a little bit is
insight and the Enlightenment dictating
to faith well this is the way things are
let me tell you we might actually if we
want to you know play off of
contemporary language we could call it
enlightenment splaining right sort of
like mansplaining you know how the men
tell women well by the way feminism
means this and that that's what the
Enlightenment does with faith
it tells faith well here's why you're an
error because you of course have just
been engaging in this projection of
consciousness outside of itself without
realizing it and that's irrational and
and we're gonna leave you behind
eventually well faith doesn't go away
quite so easily because as Hegel is
going to point out there's something
like faith going on in enlightenment as
well this is what the dirty little
secret of enlightenment isn't it and
there's more to say about this this is a
really important topic to come to but
let's take a look at the text so he says
the way in which enlightenment
apprehends its object in the first
instance and generally is that it takes
it as pure insight not right
itself therein declares it to be error
so what's going on in insight he says in
the insight as such consciousness
apprehends its object grasps its object
in such a way that it becomes the
essence of consciousness so it sort of
takes it into consciousness or if you
like the object stays out there but as
Hegel says it becomes permeated by
consciousness and why is it able to do
that because consciousness is already
there we've seen this so many times
already why is it that reason can extend
everything because reason is already out
there it just needs to be brought back
home too you know we might say capital
our reason or the reason of the
individual being the world is rational
and we can make sense of it
consciousness can grasp its object
because the object already is for
consciousness this is the way insight
works so he says you know when it
becomes an object that conscious
consciousness permits in in this
consciousness preserves itself abides
with itself remains present to itself
and since it is thus the movement of the
object brings it into existence makes it
be what it is gives its it importance
gives it its weight its heft its its
sense its meaning
so this is a process that's going on all
the time
for insight and the enlightened person
is supposed to realize this but isn't
understanding this at this point in time
so notice what Hegel does here he says
well that's pretty similar to faith
isn't it what is enlightenment say about
faith what is enlightenment explain to
faith about itself says enlightenment
rightly declares faith to be something
and you know why why is it rightly well
we've already seen this back with the
unhappy consciousness and other you know
manifestations of of religion this is
part of the essence of faith but it does
project the absolute outside of itself
and fail to realize that that is also
conscious
us projecting itself at the same time
that it loses or negates itself in the
absolute it's really playing a sort of
game it's it's putting the absolute out
there so it can run to meet it or pine
away for its absence but it's really
itself that it's looking for faith is a
form of consciousness
so he says enlightenment tells faith
that the absolute being is a being of
its own consciousness something that's a
creation of consciousness itself that
God or even that non God if you want to
be you know a mystic or something like
that and say oh you know there's a guy
head above God or you know it's
emptiness or you know can't speak about
it or whatever well that's still a
projection of consciousness and it's
essentially I don't want to say figment
of your imagination because that implies
that we're still merely in the realm of
picture thinking and there's a certain
depth to this right but it is coming
according to Hegel through this process
of projection this by the way is
something that Feuerbach and at some of
the other Teague aliens Marx Turner
these are they're going to pick up on
this aspect of faith and say well that's
that's really what all fate does all
religion does this isn't where Hegel is
going to end things of course but that
is what the Enlightenment tells faith so
he goes on he says what enlightenment
declares to be an error and a fiction
when faith is doing it what about what
enlightenment is doing the same damn
thing that's that's the critique here
that enlightenment has to make of itself
and that faith is actually going to be
the one generally to make it against the
Lightman because enlightenment Nate
might not be honest enough with itself
about what it's doing it's doing the
same thing as faith he says what
enlightenment declares to be an error of
fiction something created is what
enlightenment is doing enlightenment
that wants to teach
this new wisdom doesn't tell it anything
new all it does is change the channel
change the flavor you've got
enlightenment flavor you got faith
flavor one is not necessarily better
than the other but enlightenment is
giving itself airs as being
fundamentally different now Hegel tells
us something really interesting that's
going to come to this this crux right
he says enlightenment object is also
four inches that's a pure essence of its
own consciousness consciousness reaches
out creates its other right that it can
exist in relation to and he says so that
this consciousness does not take itself
to be lost and negated in that object
but rather puts its trust in it or you
know literally just trusts it you know
for Thailand is a verb that we get you
know for Thailand from here as the act
of trusting so he says as Hegel going on
it puts its trust in it it finds itself
as this particular consciousness or as
self-consciousness precisely in the
object now notice what he says next
whomsoever I trust his certainty of
himself is for me the certainty of
myself isn't that an interesting insight
whoever I trust his certainty of himself
is my certainty of myself there is a
reciprocity there a inextricable
relation that offers the possibility not
merely of reconciliation for
consciousness but of what the
recognition that consciousness as self
consciousness has been seeking this
entire time everything finally comes
together everybody is acknowledged right
everybody is known in who they are and
knows themself for who they are now
we're getting a little utopian we're
getting a little bit beyond ourselves at
this point but but it's
they have that in mind because that's
driving this process right so he says I
recognize in this person who I trust my
own being for self know that he
acknowledges it and that it is for him
purpose and essence when I trust
somebody I'm counting on them those
words purpose and essence are really
important here when I trust somebody I'm
counting on that person not just to do
what they say but if I really trust in
them and I have this relation with them
I am trusting that they respect me as an
end as having ends Zek right that I
choose purposes or set purposes for
myself and I'm not going to simply be
deprived of these essence as well what
is important for me what matters to me
also matters to them they take it into
account they don't just say oh I filled
my contract so screw you you're on your
own if you really have this relationship
of trust there's something more going on
there so now it says you know this is
very important this is a very good thing
this is what the Enlightenment is
supposed to be offering us but now
notice what Hegel says trust however is
faith right why because the
consciousness of the believer the one
who has faith the one who you know
believes is directly related to its
object and is thus also in intuitively
aware that it is one with it and in it
the relationship of the religious
believer to the absolute is not merely
the self-abnegation losing yourself it
is also a relationship of trust very
much like the one that has just been
laid out here it's just one that doesn't
recognize that that's what's going on
anymore than the Enlightenment
necessarily recognizes what's going on
so he says since what is object for me
is that that in which I recognize myself
I
and for myself at the same time in that
object in the form of another
self-consciousness there's a projection
of self-consciousness into being the
other now what we should do here I think
is actually change object here to other
other what other self self-consciousness
all right
what is object for me is that in which I
recognize myself I can only truly as we
know from the self consciousness section
I can only truly recognize myself not
just in a piece of chalk not just in
words on a chalkboard but in and other
somebody else somebody who I am related
to in this relationship now of trust
which now we've seen to be a form of
faith so is what's going on in faith
that much different than what's going on
up here
Hegel is not actually telling you yes
it's exactly the same he's saying
enlightenment is itself discovering this
first it has to struggle against that
and it's not going to want to admit it
for quite a while but it is going to
discover it it's helped up by faith also
putting out wait a second the stuff that
you guys criticize us for aren't you
doing that too so that that's also
helpful so he says the object of the
form of another self-consciousness that
is one which has become in that object
alienated from the particular
individuality that is from its natural
and contingent existence but which
remain partly remains there there in
self-consciousness in that object is an
essential consciousness just as pure
insight is this is the transcendence of
the spiritual it doesn't lose of course
its body it's its particularity as this
person or that person but it means more
than that and
that's important so he goes on and he
says the notion the the concept that the
Griffith of pure insight implies not
merely that consciousness recognizes
itself in the object of its insight and
is immediately present in it without
first leaving the element of thought
returning to itself that all is
happening but consciousness is aware of
itself as being the mediating movement
aware of itself as being the activity of
producing the object so there's there's
a again to take you know the contrast
between faith and enlightenment
enlightenment is is full becoming fully
conscious that it is producing this
relationship faith of course is still
you know in the dark about how this is
actually working sort of denigrating the
human side of it for what is actually
also the human side but as but as but as
you know much more projected as the
eternal the absolute something greater
than it but they're they have the same
structure here the only difference is
one of them knows what's going on and
the other one is somewhat confused about
it so he says this unity of itself is
unity of self an object is thereby
explicit for it in thought but now
notice what Hegel says faith to is this
consciousness how so
we just said faith was confused about
what's going on with it
well yes and no a little bit what does
faith do is faith merely a belief that
projects something else something else
out there or is faith active I mean this
was something that theologians have
given a lot of thought to this goes all
the way back to you know letters talking
about how one ought to behave in the
early church think about Paul's letters
think about James faith that doesn't
actually do anything isn't real faith so
here Hegel talks about obedience and
action he says these form and necessary
moments
through which the certainty that
absolute being is comes about you're not
really certain you don't really have
faith if you're not actually doing
anything in relation to that absolute
yeah we see the importance of the
practical over the merely speculative
for Hegel so he says this action of
faith doesn't make it appear as if the
absolute being is produced by it but the
absolute being of faith he says is
essentially not the abstract essence
that would exist beyond the
consciousness of the believer so what
what is it if the spirit this is very
interesting it's the spirit of the
religious community so what is being
projected isn't just some object that's
sitting out there this is how this this
faith that Hegel's talking about is
different from the unhappy consciousness
the religious community this is
prefiguring what is going to happen in
the religion section and in the absolute
knowing section what is the religious
community the religious community is
other people of faith who are conscious
who are other self consciousnesses
recognition honor kennen is happening
not just through the Enlightenment but
also in the religious community so he
says it's the spirit of the religious
community the unity of the abstract
essence and and self-consciousness then
he says that it be the spirit of the
community this requires as the necessary
moment the action of the community it's
not enough but this is very interesting
it's not enough you can't really have a
community that's just people all
believing the same thing but nobody
actually doing anything you need rituals
you need a place to gather even if
you're doing it virtually online you're
still needing some sort of corporeality
even if it's merely a virtual visual one
in order to do that I remember when I
was a kid you know and we didn't want to
go to church on Sunday we would try to
talk my mom into accepting us sitting
there and watching a show that was
called Mass
or shut-ins and we'd say well we could
watch that and it would be the same
thing as as going to mass and of course
she wasn't having a thing of it instead
she'd say that is indeed for shut-ins
for people who are stuck and can only
participate through watching and
somebody will come and bring them
communion so there's a net court again
corporeality there's action going on we
were trying to say the idea is good
enough that she was insisting no no and
she was right in hagel sense here right
so she goes on and he says it's this
spirit only by being produced by
consciousness rather it does not exist
as the spirit of the community without
hat without having been produced by
consciousness it is human beings
according to Hegel that make the
religious community it's not that God is
there beforehand and then like you know
says everybody get around I'm going to
give you a message ok now you're a
community now do the things know there's
there's a dialectic back and forth and
the human beings are really the ones
involved in is essentially from Hegel's
perspective creating that that that you
know other that absolute other who's out
there who that has recuperated into the
community so he says for as essential as
is the producing of it this is equally
essentially not the sole ground of
absolute being only a moment
absolute being is at the same time in
and for itself so now we're going to
have to see great what is absolute being
how does that enter in here and you know
now we've also a little bit lost the
thread what just happened to
enlightenment here this is enlightenment
being left behind this now we're talking
about faith in the religious community
or are we going to come back to it again
trust however is faith so there's
something like faith going on in both of
these and there's the kind of trust that
we find enlightenment permeating the
religious community the functioning
religious community not the
dysfunctional religious community as
well
you